see people lie cheat steal
disappoint yeah they're hypocrites
you know they tell you what they think
you want to hear
now i don't fall into that category
[Music]
welcome to fake gurus number eight today
we're talking about dan pena now i'm
sorry you guys
just had to witness that dan pina only
responds
to the highest levels of testosterone so
i i had to get in my
my muscle shirt
so you listen to me dan we've got some
talking to do
okay dan pina if you don't know is the
self-proclaimed
50 billion dollar man in fact there's a
lot that's self-proclaimed about him
but we're just gonna go over three
things number one
his testosterone levels rich
which everyone knows is the most
important thing
that a man has and dan pena
he's all about high testosterone levels
our first clip our first clip is called
i will win the testosterone contest
dan let's see what dan has to say
come on dad uh my blood samples uh come
back good
and my testosterone level is off
the [ __ ] chart your friend dave
asprey and my friend dave asprey
says that a guy 40 years old
which doesn't apply to us but a guy 40
years old can have
uh testosterone levels of between four
and seven or eight hundred
that sounds about right uh
a couple of the guys just had their test
done that came to the last seminar less
than 300.
okay three years ago my results
and we were talking about it and so one
of the students and uh
it was uh uh 1750.
okay i just did it six months ago again
more than 2500. your testosterone's
going up
whoa dan whoa normal average human range
600 around 600 you're telling me dam
pena has a testosterone level
of 1700 then seven months later whatever
months later he takes it again
and it's 2500 now he's a 70 year old fat
guy
he's got a 2500 testosterone level of
course that's nothing when you talk
about someone
like me but
but that's pretty high it's pretty high
makes you wonder if he's exaggerating
about anything else
is dan even is that even the 50 billion
dollar
list i googled it okay i already googled
it i already didn't know the answer
but for you i'll be surprised
daniel steven pena was known as dan pena
the 15 billion dollar man and the
trillion dollar man
dan get get a hold of yourself okay
you're not the trillion dollar man
okay he's an american businessman and
multi-million multi-millionaire
the 50 billion dollar man is a
millionaire
net worth for 450 million
dan you've exaggerated
uh what is that a hundred times
you're a hundred times poorer than you
say you are you should have said you're
the four million dollar man and it would
have been impressive when you're the 450
million dollar man
okay so he's the 50 billion dollar man
who has 450 million dollars which tells
us
that dan exaggerates by about a factor
of a hundred
so knowing that we can actually
calculate his real testosterone level so
if he says he has a 2500
but he's a he's an ob 70 year old let's
see
we divide it by 100 his actual
testosterone level
is a 25. good job dan you know what damn
we don't judge people like that okay
that doesn't make you any worse at
business
just having less testosterone i can't
figure out how to get in the camera
angle
okay 25 is nothing to be ashamed of but
now
we come to the part you've been waiting
for which is dan
killing a bear with his bare hands
yes yes it's time it's time will i stop
chewing this gum yes i'm an idiot for
not doing that sooner sorry
all right let's watch the let's let's
just see where he talks about it so
so the first time we hear about the man
the bear of course it's on the joe rogan
podcast where else would it be
oh god okay is this a brown bear or a
black bear
brown so we're chasing this bear down
right on the borderline of alaska
and whatever the canadian province is up
there so then he runs again and so i
chase him some more
and make a long story short by the time
i unloaded all five because it only has
five shells
he's he's wounded he would have died
probably in an hour
or two hours but he's still you know
dangerous so then i
jumped on him and uh stabbed him and
said wait what
so then you jump on a bear
so then i jumped on him and uh stabbed
him
70-80 times jesus christ
70 or 80 times but i mean i'm just you
know i'm just
jacked up where are you stabbing them
what part i stabbed him in the chest
around the head the neck in here i was
trying to hit a main artery
wait they stabbed him in the front the
bear is just gonna swat you
you're done if a bear tags you oh
geez trying to bite you oh yeah he's
with a big claws you know but i'm
staying
under the clock and he's losing
coordination he could have got me but he
didn't
see you're just playing like bob and
weave oh
damn there okay so he says
no i jumped on this wounded bear he's
stabbing it to death
the bear's actually swiping at him
according to his story
all right so that's kind of whatever
that never happened so i thought that
was the dumbest thing i've ever heard
but then dan changes his maybe he
realized how dumb it was
he changes his story later on to make it
sound more plausible
but it's clearly not the same story
anymore talking to london the london
real guy who does not push back on
anything he says it's unbelievable
and you stab him and he's gone no no no
no no no he fell down
and you want to you want to jump on him
from the back
whoa whoa dan whoa
whoa wait you jumped on him from the
back now you were
up front stabbing him in here and he was
swatting you and you were stuck and
weaving what happened to that dan
what happened to that mr 2500
testosterone
okay you got to keep our story straight
here
even look look this is the funny thing
the one the london real guy
who's like i guess a big fan of it i
don't know their situation
he knows the story you can tell he knows
the story because he points
to sort of where the dan pena would have
been stabbing him if he had just been
like this
because he obviously saw the joe rogan
missed you and you stabbed him
no no look look look he goes you stabbed
him and he tries to point to the thing
and then damn people was like i changed
the story though wait wait
oh no no he fell down and you want to
you want to jump on him from the back
not the front
okay oh look watch the guy
the guy knows he's alive but he doesn't
know what to do so he's like okay
because in the front
i mean they can do a lot of [ __ ]
damage okay oh they can do
a lot of damage can they i stab him in
the chest
around the head the neck in here i was
trying to hit a main artery and he's he
trying to
how are you going to do that he's laying
on his stomach you dummy how you going
to do that
dan mr 50 billion
mr 50 billion bite you want oh yeah easy
with the big claws you know but i'm
staying
under the closet because in the front i
mean they can do a lot of [ __ ] damage
okay dan i'm starting to i'm starting to
think
you may be a bit of an exaggerator here
okay
i don't know what to say guys i didn't
make this fake guru
to talk about everything this guy did
that's wrong that i think is ridiculous
he's got like this
ten thousand i don't know exactly how
much it costs it's like ten thousand 000
or something ridiculous
core master course or whatever where he
promises you the world
but all i ask all i ask okay the reason
i make this video is because
when he's promising you that think about
the other things he says are true he
says he's the
50 billion dollar man does he have 50
billion no
he says he has a testosterone level of
2500
well actually he said it was 1700 then
it became 2500
like a year later or something is that
true
probably probably not you know i don't
know for sure okay
all i know is that if he has a 2500 100
then i have a
10 000. what does a scouter say about
his power level
it's over nine thousand but
where's davao he dares to say that he
killed a bear with his bare hands and
then back
down from his own story if you're gonna
tell a story like that
you better be willing to back it up
backing it up is something a 2500
testosterone kind of man would do and
you didn't do that dan
so it makes me wonder about the rest of
you anyway
that concludes today's fake guru this is
the start guys
i hope you know first of all new studio
new studio this is the start of a little
something i want to call
fake guru friday okay i know you guys
love this channel pretty much
the only reason anyone watches this
channel anymore is for fake gurus
so we're gonna make it a regular theme
guys fake guru
friday first friday next friday i'm
probably going to miss actually i'm on
vacation but
next the friday afternoon maybe we could
get something worked out anyway
expect fake gurus on friday i'm really
excited to bring that series to you guys
and maybe some others on this special
special channel
where some of you think i get a little
unhinged to which i say
hey hey you hey you in the comments you
in the ba
who's about to comment hey stop it i
know what you're thinking you're
thinking hey
hey steven you you dummy you have a
you have a some schmutz on your shirt
you're gonna comment about
that you're saying they're a stain it's
not a stain it's a style number
two if it was a stain maybe it's because
i spilled a little bit of coffee on
myself okay get cut me
some slack okay we're operating on a
very small budget
i don't have money for shirts and things
i'm not a rich man over here
okay i'm not pissed off that i didn't
see it until
the post edit okay i'm not pissed about
it i just don't mention it please
number two some of you guys are saying
wow
stephen you must not have done your
research because dan the 50 billion
dollar man
he doesn't say he owns 50 billion he
says he brought 50 billion dollars of
value
oh well first of all that's a lie
that's uh how could even he even
quantify that do you just take success
for all your students
i mean like does everybody i ever ran
into contact with and gave advice to
does that contribute to my net worth
no number two that's just a way of
deflecting from the facts okay
he calls himself the 50 billion dollar
man because he wants to be associated
with billions because he knows
young impressionable people who are
desperate for leaders
they look to who is successful so
obviously no one cares about the 450
million dollar man oh that's all right
it's all right
okay but they look to the 50 billion
dollar man he does it strategically so
he does it with the explicit knowledge
that people misinterpret things like
that and they're if you call yourself
the 50 billion dollar man people think
you have 50 billion
he's not dumb he's not ignorant to that
fact he does it very intentionally so i
wanted to cut that
nip that in the bud okay that's all
[Music]
bye
[Music]